it's the years anniversary of archwell
now
and as we approach that anniversary we
are seeing the company change already
and and if you speak to sources at
archwell they
say that these are very positive changes
so the chief of staff catherine who was
a big hire
for the couple she worked with the gates
foundation before
very very respected and sought after is
now
stepping down as chief of staff she's
going to retain
a senior advisory role for archwell
she's going to set up
her own organization and we understand
that will work closely with archwell i'm
told there's been no fallout
we we do know that the couple
historically have had a high turnover of
staff but
the the transition of catherine i'm told
is is very amicable and she will
continue working
with the couple now this change is good
news for
their head of staff over here in the uk
james holt who's worked with a couple
for five years is
one of the most loyal and long-standing
members of staff and he will move
across to archwell as chief executive
director so a big promotion for him
which will see him
working very closely with the couple on
their philanthropic ventures
and but they have taken on new recruits
they've got a brit
ben browning who's going to be
overseeing all of their content he's won
emmys and countless awards for his tv
production
apparently he's hugely excited to be
working with the company and i think
it's worth just mentioning really that
you know they grew this company during a
pandemic
and this is their first real venture and
post-royal life and thus far it's it's
looking to be very successful we've had
the podcast
now spotify we've of course got the big
multi-million dollar deal with netflix
we now know that that's gonna be ben
browning overseeing that content and
hearing that we're gonna get news about
that content in the not too distant
future and so this is a very exciting
period for archwell it's growing they're
accumulating new stuff
and very soon we'll be hearing i'm sure
exciting news about the content
exactly what they'll be doing for
netflix and spotify
you